speaking of voting in November by the
way Texas has had an acting Secretary of
State and this man named David Whitley
of course a Republican has now resigned
after wrongly questioning the
citizenship of almost 100,000 people and
even more hilarious is that in his
resignation letter he didn't even
mention the botched voter purge that
took place in Texas at all the
resignation letter is a blatant
whitewashing of what actually happened
the voter purge was actually ended back
in April and there was a settlement that
was reached with civil rights groups who
sued over it and what's even more insane
about all of this is that under the
terms of the agreement that was reached
over this voter purge the next Secretary
of State whoever it ends up being can
keep trying to identify non-citizens and
remove them from the voter rolls as long
as they put in place some better
screening methods so that they get more
accurate results now that piece actually
makes sense I mean if you zoom out
states should be allowed to remove
non-citizens from voter rolls that
that's perfectly reasonable the problem
is that in practice it's been made
crystal clear that it's a tactic
motivated by voter suppression to help
Republicans period the way it went down
is that they claimed to have found
95,000 non-citizens registered to vote
they started sending these lists out to
the individual county officials to start
pulling those people off of the voter
rolls and then very quickly they
admitted and a court agreed oh yeah that
list was bogus it wasn't actually made
up of non-citizens registered to vote
but of course by then it was too late to
stop the propaganda war effect Donald
Trump was tweeting about it saying look
rampant voter fraud here's an example
from Texas and Trump actually claimed
that of those 95,000 non-citizens who
were supposedly identified by Texas
58,000 voted and of course everything
was a lie a federal judge ruled that way
saying there wasn't widespread voter
fraud and this Whitley guys strategy was
a complete and total mess so here are
the key takeaways number one this is all
part of the untrue story that Trump's
been telling us since November of 2016
Republicans have been telling us for
even longer than that that millions of
people are voting illegally with Trump
specifically it was three to five
million people voted illegally Hillary
Clinton didn't really win the popular
vote it was because of those three to
five million illegal boats this is so
laughably false at this point that I
don't even want to spend that much time
on it the more important thing to
understand here is that we can't let the
right play games with this to make it
seem as though we on the Left want
people to vote illegally okay because
every time we call out the horrible
implementation of these strategies that
the right does deliberately to
disenfranchise likely Democratic voters
or those more likely to be Democratic
voters they will say hold on lefties are
you saying you want people voting
illegally you're saying you don't want
to remove people who aren't citizens
from voter rolls see you're part of the
problem so we've got to be prepared to
take that head-on and the answer is the
position is obvious of course we want
only legal voters voting and
overwhelmingly that's what happens every
major study has found that fraudulent
votes are almost non-existent they're
statistically insignificant when it
comes to the results of actual elections
the reason that we are correct to be
suspicious and disgusted with
Republicans doing this stuff is not
because we want the legal votes it's
because it's not a problem and the right
has admitted behind closed doors and we
even have video of them admitting it in
public in some cases they are doing all
of this to hurt the left higher turnout
helps the helps the left more voting
helps the left voting access helps the
left so don't allow them to change the
narrative we're against illegal voters
they barely exist though and the real
issue is voter suppression it's not
voter fraud and this has been a at this
point I don't know it is could we say
it's a multi-decade effort to suppress
votes in a way that is strategically
advantageous to Republicans don't let
them play the games a good that this guy
Whitley has resigned bad that he was
able to whitewash the resignation with
this bogus resignation letter and now
we've got to see who it is
that the governor Abbott is going to
nominate probably won't be out until
after the 2020 election